yeah but you know what dude it's like um
you started with but you're an actor as
well yeah
like you're in boiler room right yeah so
you can do both mm-hmm it's did you do
stand-up even before you became a you
became famous first right I did stand
there's no one knows this and and I know
that there's like actors they get these
reps yeah but now every type of group
was doing stand-up but I was actually
did stand-up first
believe it or not oh wow but I got more
notoriety right away from acting but so
you would do but you know what's funny
who I where I got a lot of love is it's
the factory like I would go up and do
this little you know showcase spots and
yeah I got my first commercial agent and
then I got my first movie audition Wow
and so but I was doing like literally
open mics and I do a set here and a set
there Wow didn't get like on the regular
rotation yeah yeah
but that's how you started them that's
how I started yeah and then I got really
busy acting and like for like three
years I didn't touch a microphone yeah
you hit a big fast all right I get
scream scream as'f I mean it's yeah it
was a big movie oh yeah yeah huge but I
mean I struggled for a while yeah and
then like one of the first things I hit
it hit but I literally went from zero to
hero I mean I don't forget it's a mic I
made no money for like five and a half
years had no money right every year I me
remember my tax return was like ninety
four hundred then I got a blockbuster
campaign and one of the stars of it was
Jim Gavin well and that was 94 and I
went for 95 and I had made ninety four
hundred dollars and my paycheck from
that campaign was 98 thousand oh that
was my first like zero to hero and I was
like and I had gone probably for like a
hundred auditions couldn't get anything
but that's when I realized the power of
a business because you kind of don't get
paid for the job you get paid for all
the times you audition right and it hit
and it wasn't even here was a European
it flew me to Europe we did all this
stuff yes I mean yeah
like that yeah where you just do I I
made at zero yeah
350 Wow on what IBM campaign but I had
to wear up 98 inside aware a blooming 50
blue spacesuit IBM conferences I had to
go and walk around right there was no
air conditioning so like the sweat like
pre social media so that was your social
media play was like a juggernaut or
something with other white dude
Eric Hershberger from New York he was a
commercial actor and he was a tall white
skinny white guy like he almost looked
sickly
you know like meek and I was kind of the
short so we'd walk around these
conventions and hand out flyers dude I
did the blockbuster campaign we were the
blockbuster entertainment yeah so they
put the whole thing was in Europe so we
went to Paris we went to London and they
would have those like conferences and
they would go and bring out the team an
[Applause]
overnight card like that's crazy yeah
and then they flew in the 90s they flew
us to Tokyo Wow IBM the president of IBM
of Tokyo that's the equivalent of like a
social media influence or now yeah I
mean now you can just post a picture of
yourself in a spacesuit yeah or you'd
actually have to attend yeah and I met
this Japanese good guy any guy in a suit
older dude speaking in Japanese right
and they had a translator yeah and
basically he said would it do any
basically was asking me it was I was
hungry
right but it sounded serious you know
yeah and meet each other we're hungry
right and he takes us down these
elevator we eat with this guy yeah okay
think that the main guy right idea we go
into a restaurant there's no sign it's
just like a wooden table
with a candle in the middle really dark
yeah right we sit down and you don't
already they just start bringing out
food right and they bring out a steak it
was a
a stick I never had one Wow from Japan
was a cutter melting your [ __ ] mouth
Wow I remember that meal distinctly
because it was like because right before
that like three weeks I was living with
12 guys in a two-bedroom apartment in
silver what year is it 97 98
were they convenient no no they were
just uh skaters and my brother and
homeless people I was living with like a
lot of guy we man we man sometimes yeah
lettuce skaters would come into town and
they just crashed they called the
dumpster so they crash at the dumpster
in Silver Lake Wow yeah and it was I was
on Sanborn and it was a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yes pigsty Wow yeah because back then
there was the you know like it's now hip
there's cute restaurant yeah yeah but
back then it was ms-13 and a couple of
taco trucks it wasn't like what it was
you know um but yeah remember that man
it changed it changed me that one thing
but you know there could be now
[Laughter]
[Music]